I'm Henry edmoni I'm a professor of
Robotics today I'll be answering your
questions from Twitter this is robot
support down low
[Music]
at AG
2624 3 asks why are people so obsessed
with making human-like robots we all
need to chill I don't disagree
human-like robots are great usually a
robot that's not shaped like a human is
more robust and more capable of doing
the task it needs to do one example of a
humanoid robot is Sophia the robot some
people would call this category of
robots Androids Sophia is a highly
realistic robot but if you've ever
watched Sophia you know that there's
still a gap between what the robot is
doing and what we actually expect from
people this is often called The Uncanny
Valley very human-like robots can fall
into that uncanny valley and make people
pretty uncomfortable at Furby Factor
asks how do you program personality into
a robot it is hard to Define exactly
what makes a personality robots are just
programs for example if somebody makes a
funny joke should the robot laugh or
should the robot roll his eyes this all
has to be created in software when we're
programming robots what we're doing is
building a set of instructions if you
run into an obstacle backup to get more
complex Behavior you can't rely just on
pre-specified rules that's where
something like machine learning comes in
in machine learning we are building
algorithms which are basically just sets
of instructions that can based on the
information that they're getting adapt
themselves to learn the right kinds of
output at Christini asks can you pick up
a single m m with a robot arm it kind of
depends on the robot arm with this one
it's going to be a little hard some
robots are only robot arms and those are
called manipulators like this one right
here
ah so close this kind of fine motor
manipulation is really challenging for
robots robots don't have the level of
motion and movement that we do in our
fingers the other thing that we use in
our fingers that robots don't have is a
sense of touch that allows us to tell
when we are actually gripping something
so that we can know that it's able to be
picked up this box has fiducial markers
on it these are essentially QR codes
that allow the robot camera to recognize
what orientation and position the box is
in supposed to make it easier for the
robot to pick up the box autonomously
at SEO Chase asks do you think robots
will one day take over all of our jobs
the real benefit of robots is taking
over the 3DS the dull dirty and
dangerous jobs that we probably don't
want human beings to be doing anyway
people are working on underwater robots
that can detect underwater landmines
some people have worked on robots that
can go into nuclear facilities after an
accident and shut off different valves
but I do hope that robots are able to
make people better at their jobs and
free people up to do things that they're
actually good at and they actually want
to do at Big Tech Prof asks what is
elon's goal for the Tesla Optimus robot
Elon Musk does not consult with me but
my understanding is that he's looking to
build a general purpose home robot one
that can do everything from cleaning up
your room to unloading your dishwasher
to design a robot that's capable of
doing more than just one thing takes a
ton of work and a ton of investigation
Tesla is pretty well positioned to do so
their autonomous driving division has a
huge computer vision capability and
they're building the kinds of batteries
that would be needed to power this
sophisticated machine for a long period
of time at display your CV says what are
the major problems in the field of
Robotics today there are a few big
challenges that we face today when we're
trying to get robots out into the real
world the first one is perception how do
we get robots to see and hear and
interact with their environment and
actually understand what it is that
they're looking at another one is
actuation how do we get robots to move
around in ways that allow them to
achieve their tasks and finally another
big problem is intelligence how do we
make our robots smart enough to plan the
right kind of action to do in order to
achieve what they're trying to one major
area of interest to me is how we get
robots to interact with people like
personal home robots or Healthcare
robots that are helping nurses and
doctors at Alice J and Taylor asks I
just want to know how Boston robotics
plans to deal with humans who think
pushing robots over is hilarious there
are lots of people who are doing
research on how robots should respond to
various forms of abuse one that I like
the most is that when a robot is being
kicked by kids in a shopping mall
researchers found that if it just rolls
to the nearest adult the kids will stop
at a leveres asks have you ever had a
genuine social interaction with a robot
although I can't say that I've had a
deep social interaction with a robot I
can say that I have felt social
reactions to robots
for example this is curry curry is
really cute
if you pet Curry's head it'll purr
and that kind of response actually does
generate some social interaction for me
A lot of people are working on social
robots to help people in the home or in
Elder Care situations and in these cases
it's really important that the robot is
able to connect socially with people for
example it should tell when somebody's
frustrated or not wanting to take a bite
of food or somebody's tired and should
just go to bed detecting these social
cues is still really challenging to
build into an algorithm and that's a
huge part of social robotics at Tomas
cosmeter asks how hashtag AI is being
used in hashtag robotics Ai and Robotics
have a lot of overlap AI is all about
how you get systems to act intelligently
robotics is about taking devices and
putting them out in the real world and
having them move around and interact
with the environment or with people so
in order for robots to work we really
need the AI to support them but robotics
is more than just the AI that supports
them it's also about the mechanics of
building a physical system and the
electronics of developing safe circuitry
robotics Nai big overlap but still two
separate fields at Joe Maroney asks
self-driving cars are already on the
road when there's a problem how do we
understand the decisions AI makes
self-driving cars are essentially a type
of robot moving around in the world and
making Intelligent Decisions based on
what they're perceiving these algorithms
that robots are using for decision
making are sort of like black boxes
inputs come in in the form of
perceptions or knowledge and then
outputs come out in the form of
actuation the robot decides to merge or
decides to stop but that black box can
be very very complicated and because of
that we need something like explainable
AI in order to back out the processes
that the robot used to get to where it
was going ee World online line asks what
types of sensors are used in robots some
robots have cameras like this one that
can detect not just color images but
also depths using infrared other robots
have physical sensors like pump sensors
or capacitive sensors that respond to
touch time of flight sensors or other
kinds of ways excuse me my robot is
escaping
the original roombas also had bump
sensors that's how they knew they were
running into something lots of robots
also use audio sensors hey Curry foreign
like that at 24 7 press release asks
what are swarm robots and how are they
learning from insects if you watch the
Olympics you've seen these beautiful
displays of Lights floating in space
those are swarm robots swarm robots are
groups of robots that operate in a
collective have intelligence that's
distributed across the entire system so
that no one of them has the central
information these are designed and
inspired by the way insect swarms
operate and it's just one example of the
ways that robotics has been inspired by
biology at Robo tricks one how six axis
industrial robots work six axis robots
are called that because they can move in
six different directions here's an
example of a six axis robot it can move
in three directions of physical space
left and right
up and down
and forward and back
they can also move in three directions
of orientation space pitch
yeah
and roll these robots work by deciding
how to move every joint in the kinematic
chain in order to get the robot hand
which we call an end effector to the
right position this process of
calculating how the joints will need to
move to put the undefector in the right
spot is called inverse kinematics at spy
codex asks do you know who invented the
first robot in history what was it so
what makes a robot anyway it needs to be
able to sense its environment plan using
that sensor input in some smart way and
then act on the world so given those
criteria for being a robot the first
broadly accepted real robot was shaky it
was invented in the mid 60s in
California it was a robot that had a big
television camera on top and it had
wheels and it could take instructions
and roll around a different obstacle
course with objects in its way that was
the foundation of a lot of the robotics
that we do today at edgeronia asks what
if the only thing that's preventing a
full-on global robot takeover are a
handful of captcha servers captcha
servers are servers that run those kind
of annoying little answers that you have
to give to prove that you're not a robot
you have to identify pictures that have
particular objects in them what you're
actually doing with those captcha
servers is training intelligent systems
on the back end companies are using that
data to try to build better classifiers
for things like traffic lights or
bicycles we've seen lots of movies where
robots are the evil beings that are
taking over from humans the reality is
we're still really far from any notion
of robots being capable enough to
operate in environments in order to have
any kind of impact like that at local
plumbing he asks could Star Wars droids
be real we are
pretty far from robots like C-3PO and
R2D2 they are showing super Advanced
versions of the technologies that
researchers are working on right now now
these are two very different approaches
and they serve different purposes the
C-3PO which is a humanoid robot it's
shaped like a person it walks upright it
uses language that people use to
communicate including the variety of
different accents and dialects that
people use and then we have our 2D2 it's
explicitly not humanoid kind of looks
like a trash can it uses Wheels instead
of legs to move around the language that
it speaks is beeps and boobs and humans
have learned the robot's language that's
not something that we see today most of
the time we are getting robots to adapt
to people and not the other way around
at Stephen Boyle 3 asks why do we need
robotic delivery cool boxes driving
around slowly getting in everyone's way
are we just making robots for the sake
of making robots the idea idea behind
delivery robots is to make it more
convenient for people to acquire things
like groceries or delivery food the idea
of these robots is worthy but right now
the reality of their implementation is
that they move around pretty slow and
they often do block traffic so the
technology hasn't yet caught up to the
reality we don't want to make robots for
the sake of making robots but I think a
lot of the times we're building robots
because we're trying to make life a
little bit easier or a little bit more
equal for people at CIF underscore KH
asks could a real-life Westworld be in
our future it takes a lot to make a
robot that is indistinguishable from a
human being this is because humans are
super sophisticated we have dozens of
muscles just in our face to make facial
expressions getting a robot to be
capable of that requires dozens of
motors and that's not really a realistic
thing right now I'd say we're still a
pretty long way off from these kinds of
hyper realistic robots like in Westworld
I at asme journals asks what are the
Nanobots Nanobots are tiny robots that's
what the word Nano means in their name
they are designed for a variety of
applications including things like
medicine going into the human body
because they're so small it's hard to
get electronics that will fit into them
often they're designed to respond to the
chemical environment for example
something that you might find in the
human body it's actually this really
interesting connection between Robotics
and chemistry and Material Science at
meteorologically s how is robot
simulation software used to program
robots virtually simulation is a huge
part of what we do in robot development
we do a lot of our testing in simulation
so that we know that when we bring those
into the real world that they are more
likely to work simulations can be
limited though you need to replicate
real world physics including friction
and different kinds of forces and wind
shear that can be exceeded
computationally expensive simulations
are still easier than putting the robots
in the real world and so there's still a
hugely popular tool in robotics at
bliley Tech asks how are hashtag robots
used in hashtag space exploration these
robots are being deployed autonomously
to roll around collect samples take
measurements and do all of the
scientific data finding that we need to
do to understand what's in space we've
had several robots sent to Mars here at
Carnegie Mellon University where I work
we have a huge project on building
robots that are capable of operating
autonomously on the moon there's a robot
that's actually being developed and
tested here right now and we're hoping
to send it into space soon at distrelc
asks how are cobots helping to transform
industry a cobot is a collaborative
robot specifically designed to work with
human beings one big area that people
are looking at for kobas right now is in
shared manufacturing so you have a
person who is building something in a
factory and the robot is able to do
things like fetch materials for them or
hold Parts while they do the fine motor
manipulation in this case the robot is
collaborative for a few reasons one is
that it's sharing space and tools with
human beings but another is that it's
actually being trained by a human being
so it's learning how to do this from a
person and that's a big part of
collaboration is this kind of sharing of
information at wizkelecap says
agricultural robots a growing Trend in
fact it is there's a huge problem right
now in growing enough food and
distributing it to get to all the people
in the world and people are looking to
robotics to help solve that robots that
can roll down a field of crops and tell
a farmer whether the crop is healthy or
needs different kinds of nutrients or
robots that can very quickly sort
through strawberry plants to tell the
farmer which ones are going to grow well
and which ones need to be thrown out the
hope is that these agricultural robots
are going to be able to help farmers
increase their impact and make farming
in general more sustainable those are
all the questions for today thanks so
much for all the interesting questions
and thanks for watching robot support
she's sleeping